visit expressvpn.com yang and get three
extra months of
expressvpn for free
[Music]
[Applause]
the nba's return to play was in part
about
black lives matter uh social justice
messaging
and that became like a huge part of the
nba really
in a way that i think was unprecedented
in american sports history
the players deserve the credit because
it was a condition of them coming back
you know the moment
demanded it the players a lot of them
would start every press conference every
media availability they had
talking about some social justice racial
justice
cause i could get their first question
and say okay before i get into that
and they would talk about briana taylor
then they progressed as we got closer to
the election with
voting becoming their their major
issue and they were a little bit
embarrassed because
the media doing their research said
these guys are going to tell us to vote
20 percent of them are registered to
vote
and chris paul is president of the
players association
took it upon himself and very quickly
like
within days 90 of the players
were registered to vote half of the
teams had 100
registration to vote
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks
one of the smartest men in basketball
current nba on tnt analyst
fresh from the bubble mr stan van gundy
welcome stan
i'm honored to say the least to be with
you
uh you know followed your presidential
campaign
love all your ideas and as i've told you
before we got on here
i'm intimidated as hell we have a
in basketball andrew in basketball
nba we're always looking for match-ups
we always look at match-ups and
in terms of intellect this is such a
mismatch that
i know i'm the match-up that gets picked
on
are you kidding we're here to pick your
brains dan because you've had an
epic uh career and run that obviously
you know like still has a ways to go
um i have a couple of nba related
questions or
a number but to give you a sense of my
background uh
like i grew up a huge knicks fan and so
my first
uh exposure to you and your family was
through your brother jeff
when like jeff van gundy becomes the
nick's head coach which i'm sure was a
very proud moment for
you with the entire family like oh my
gosh my little brother just became like
the
like the head coach of the knicks where
you have this glamour franchise
you know pat riley uh pat riley steps
down
uh he tries to bring jeff with him and
then the knicks say no way
and then he ends up giving you a call
being like all right like
let me get uh another van gundy so you
join your brother
jeff in the nba uh and then don nelson
gets fired and jeff becomes a freaking
nba head coach and i was a huge knicks
fan during that time and i was like
jeff van gundy like our head coach and
the the deck was stacked against him
because he was kind of a no-name he
hadn't like had a huge
basketball playing career clearly the
rest of it
but he but he just performed
so well as coach that as a knicks fan
like i fell in love with
him and those teams new york fell in
love with him i remember
them chanting his name like jeff van
gundy uh and his
his leadership and coaching skill were
just undeniable and so he became like
one of the most beloved coaches
uh in nick's history and then you became
you know an assistant coach of the heat
and wound up having an incredible arc
yourself so just so you know like that's
where i'm coming from where
i have i have a reverence for both you
and your brother
and everything that you've done for the
nba
i appreciate that and as long as we stay
on basketball i'm on comfortable ground
so well for you guys too
one of the reasons i love your family
story is your dad's a college coach
and i remember when i was reading about
your brother jeff's choices where he
transferred from yale to nazareth
college to be able to play
um and i'm asian you might have noticed
and so i feel like if there was like an
like if there was an asian kid who said
hey i'm going to transfer from yale to
nazareth to play d3 basketball
your parents
[Laughter]
your family's case i feel like you all
understood because basketball was so
deep in your blood
yeah well and actually he really bounced
around so he had gone to yale
to play basketball and and and he'll
tell you
you know they get certain preferred
slots the athletic teams do in the ivy
league now you
still have to meet minimum standards um
so he got one of their preferred slots
so that's how he got
into yale but then it didn't work out
basketball
wise so it's even worse andrew than
going to
nazareth college to begin with he
transferred to a junior college
in california to maintain his
eligibility
and went to menlo junior college it's
now a four-year school but he went there
for a year
then he came back and played for my
father at
brockport state in new york um
and then my dad you know at that level
you you do both
you teach and coach at the division
three level and so
my dad got caught in faculty layoffs he
could have still coached but
you can't make a living like that and so
when he left to take another job
my brother went to nazareth so he went
to four schools in five years
and um yeah bounced around and it was
funny i mean you don't leave yale you
just don't
leave yale but it worked out pretty well
for him the decision doesn't look as bad
in retrospect
as it might have looked at the time so
when did you know you wanted to be a
basketball coach like you and your
brother
no offense but you're not exactly like
towering human beings
[Laughter]
so i i have this image in my mind's eye
of you guys both being fairly normal
sized
youngsters in high school playing guard
uh
at the high school level and you
obviously both love the game deeply like
when did
you and jeff both know you know what i'm
gonna to
uh coach basketball or be in basketball
for the rest of my life
yeah i think it's probably the same for
him but for me
for sure i don't ever remember really
seriously ever wanting to do anything
else
um you know certainly when i was a kid
you know i actually thought i was you
know i wanted to be a baseball player
and then when you're 13 and you hit
under 100
you say okay that's probably not going
to take place so
from then on i remember flirting
thinking about
law and journalism for a little bit but
the only thing i ever really focused on
even from the time say i was 14 or 15
was coaching basketball and i think the
reason is
um you know my dad coached at the high
school small college junior college
levels
his whole career and loved every day of
it i mean he he will say
to people all the time that he never
worked a day in his life i mean he was
one of those lucky people
who loved what he was doing and when you
grow up in a household where you see
somebody
you know loving what they're doing every
day you you know
you just i think subconsciously say wow
that looks really cool like
he's having a lot of fun i'll do that
and so and then we were lucky not only
to be around
him but you know most of his friends
were coaches
basketball or even other sports and so
we were around it a lot
and it really looked like a great thing
to do
you know it sounds a little bit like
growing up in a family business where
you just end up absorbing or
internalizing
the energy of the family business and
then going and getting another kind of
job
uh just seems kind of uh dull
by comparison because uh you know you're
it's not drawing on
uh so many parts of yourself as
the family business does and it's true
when you get that
at a young age it's hard to
do something else i feel like you dodged
a bullet by not becoming a lawyer
journalist
no offense to those fields i mean
obviously they're great fields and the
rest of it
uh so you play basketball i want to say
for your dad
at the college level at a school that's
not you know
like super i don't think it was d1 was
it
no it's one of the state schools in new
york division three that's my level
that was my level so you go from there
and then you become an assistant coach
and then a head coach
at various schools uh and become the
head coach of wisconsin which is the d1
program that must have felt like
um like an incredible journey in itself
uh when
when they said hey stan like here's your
contract to become the head coach
at wisconsin yeah look i mean my career
has just been
one of tremendous luck um
and i don't mean that i'm not trying to
be you know
over overly modest or anything but
um i've been in the right place at the
right time and gotten a lot of breaks
when i came out of college i knew i
wanted to coach
and i had a division three background
and i looked around and
you know i would see these division
three schools that
were great schools and really nice
campuses
place to live good program and i'd say
wow if i could ever get one of those
jobs if i could ever
you know when i was 50 years old rise to
that level
i'll be happy and then you know you just
circumstances
come up and you get these incredible
chances to advance
um and at wisconsin
i was working for stu jackson who's
another former knicks head coach
um he was the head coach and he moved on
to take
the general manager's job for what was
then the vancouver grizzlies
and we were really involved in
recruiting a great in-state player in
wisconsin
and i got the wisconsin job basically
because they wanted to make sure that
they got
sam okie and so i was in the right place
at the right time now they fired me
uh within a year so it wasn't all good
but
it was still a great opportunity and
then even them firing me
they happened to fire me at what you
talked about earlier
you know a couple months after that pat
riley left the knicks couldn't bring my
brother with him and hired me so
even my timing on getting fired was
impeccable
and got me into the nba i've just hit it
i've hit it right every time
so you wind up an assistant coach at the
miami heat and you were like wow i'm in
the nba now
uh like like what what was that
transition like
um for you and your family i think at
that time you're already like a family
man right you have like um
a wife and kids at that point yeah we
had two at that point my
daughter was almost
four and my son had not turned quite a
year old when we got to miami
and you know it was overwhelming at
first i mean i was in awe i
i'll never forget andrew we got down
there and pat had a um
free agent camp you know we were sort of
looking for into the roster guys
and so we had this free agent camp
probably
30 players there um fringe nba guys
and i'm watching them you know play and
we're running this camp and i'm saying
i've never been in a gym
with this much talent and none of these
guys are even nba players i
and i'm blown away by how good everybody
was and i'll never forget
because then we go to lunch after the
first session and i'm hyped up man here
i am i'm in the nba
it's my first day and we sit down to
lunch and
we had a veteran assistant named scotty
robertson and we're sitting at the table
and as soon as pat
sat down scotty looked at him and he
said well there's nobody here that can
help us
and he just blew away 30 guys out of the
most talented group of players
that i had ever been in a gym with and i
remember thinking oh you're in a whole
new world now
wow you're like well i'm glad i kept my
mouth shut until he said that
yeah exactly because i would have i had
my list of like 12 guys that i really
[Music]
liked
i love subscription services because you
just set it and forget it
and then when you get the thing you
forget you even subscribed you're like
oh
what is this what is this delightful
package
and what could be more delightful than
some vino
bright sellers is a wine subscription
service that helps you find wine you
love
while making it more accessible for
everyone you can take a 30 second quiz
all these companies have quizzes i love
quizzes
and bright sellers will pair you with
unique and personalized wines that are
delivered right to your doorstep
you can seem really sophisticated you
can
relieve some stress in a way that's very
wholesome and healthy and for our
listeners we're giving you 50
off your first six bottle orders from
bright sellers
go to brightsellers.com yang50
that's bright sellers c-e-l-l-a-r-s
dot com slash yang50 take their seven
question quiz to get your wine matches
and receive 50
off your first six bottle order i really
like wine but i always sound like an
idiot because i don't understand what's
in it or why
i like certain types um so bright
cellars is perfect if you want to sound
a little more impressive with your
friends they send you a case
after you take this quiz and for each
type of wine they give you a card that
has
like the real details but also like some
quick talking points you remember
so you can sound smart be like this is
rich in tannins or this is made in
oak massage barrels or whatever the heck
comes with it
but it's pretty cool and very tasty so
that is brightsellers.com
yang 50 and get 50 off your first six
bottles
[Music]
[Applause]
so you're an assistant coach you become
the head coach of the heat you have a
lot of success
you then become i want to say coach of
the year in the
the magic uh take them to the finals you
actually
you pioneered um like a four
out system where i remember that year
you got the magic to the finals it was
dwight howard and a bunch of shooters
uh and that ended up um presaging this
whole revolution in the nba i don't
think it really fully took after
that finals team where shooting
mattered as much as as uh it does today
but you certainly set off a whole new
trend uh with that finals team
yeah i mean i think it was us and mike
d'antoni's teams in phoenix
um you know with us i'd like to take
credit for being an innovative genius i
because that would be a nice thing to
have after your name but
in reality again uh we sort of hit it
lucky and and i
i think about i thought about this a few
years ago i was listening
uh michael lewis gave a commencement
address at princeton and it was on the
role of luck
and in our case in in orlando we came
in and we probably would have played
pretty conventionally
but tony batea who would have been our
starting power forward next to dwight
howard
got hurt in pickup games even before
training camp started
and he was going to be out the year and
so
we just didn't really have a lot of
choices so we were going to play richard
lewis and
hito turcalu together as our forwards
neither one of them was
was a power forward at a time when teams
had big strong power forwards but
we just didn't have a lot of choices and
so
we decided to play them together and to
make it work the best we could and it
ended up
being fantastic we won 52 games that
first year
59 the second year and went to the
finals um
and again it was you know the saying
necessity is the mother of invention
that's what it was like
this is what we have how do we make the
best of it and we ended up with
something better than we
would have had had tony not gotten hurt
and there's definitely an important
lesson there which is have your power
forward to get hurt in a pickup game now
so so you have this incredibly
successful run with the magic
and you became one of the most highly
sought after free agents
coaching-wise at the end of that run and
i want to say that
like the choice for you was between the
golden state warriors and the detroit
pistons at least i think
like i don't i mean that this is just
from the outside looking in
um were you at all close to to
heading west uh and joining golden state
uh before you end up committing to the
pistons
well no but but here's what happened i
was i was
far along in the process with the
pistons
um as a matter of fact had uh
had already gotten to the point where
they had offered me the job
when the warriors called and wanted to
talk
and i just had one meeting with the
warriors
uh never got offered the job uh
and we were far along with detroit and
um very happy with that situation i've
had a lot of people say you know
uh you should have waited and see what
happened with golden state but
i don't have any regrets whatsoever and
i'm a guy who
you know like you talked about growing
up a knicks fan i grew up in the bay
area and i was a huge
warriors fan you know and i was in high
school when
rick berry led the 75 warriors to the
championship
and so the chance to go coach your
hometown team would have been excited
but again we just they were at different
points in their process
and i decided you know i like the
situation in detroit
i'm glad that i took that opportunity um
and would have liked to have won more
games but i i'm
thankful for the experience i spent a
lot of time in detroit and there's
something very very special about what's
going on in that city i mean you were a
huge part of it you were the president
of
the pistons um did you and your family
uh
i mean you must have lived there in
michigan and then maybe had like a
summer home in
in i'm guessing florida like was that
the the living situation
actually yeah we kept our um home in
central florida when we when we went to
detroit but we lived up there full time
um you know at the time we got there the
arena the palace was north of the city
so
we lived up there because that's where
the facility
was and everything else but but we did
get into detroit
a lot um detroit's a great city in a
number of ways but what it really is
it's uh
as far as for fun what we loved is it's
a
great music city it is a great concert
city and so between an amphitheater
up next to us um the dte it used to be
they used to call it pine knob
famous place up there um they had the
pistons actually owned two other
amphitheaters and then the fox theater
downtown
and the paramore and the detroit opera
house
i mean in the offseason i don't know
andrew maybe
two or three times a week my wife and i
were at
at concerts and down in the city i had
season tickets to the tigers
season tickets to the lions um we
loved detroit and the people there are
people um yeah we had a great four years
there and
i've still got two kids that live in
michigan my daughter works at the
university of michigan
my son's in grad school at uh at wayne
state and we still um
support congressional candidates out
there
uh we supported a district attorney
candidate i still care
about the city of detroit in the state
of michigan
and you know trying to make a
contribution there
yeah it has that effect on you i still
care about it too
uh i started a non-profit that started
operating in detroit in 2012 i've been
there every year since
2010 and we started working with dan
gilbert very closely
uh with my organization so he owns the
cavs doesn't people don't really think
of him as a detroit guy but you know
he's like mr detroit
um his uh operations there are the
anchor of the downtown area
uh so uh i actually had some fun
visiting him in his detroit hq where he
has
he's a huge nba fan obviously owning the
cavs so um he had like a
a basketball court in the office
building and there's like sports
paraphernalia
all over the place
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what time it is it's time to
talk about your
data and why it is getting ripped every
time you go on the internet
unless you use a vpn
and the vpn you should use according to
us is expressvpn because expressvpn
is the number one rated by cnet
wired and other people who check it out
for a living
companies use it we recommend it you
should use it too
it safeguards your data makes it so that
no one can see what you're doing
you can access some of that really racy
foreign content
because you can team into the internet
in another country
if this all sounds like your jam
expressvpn.com
yang right now you can get three months
of expressvpn for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang visit expressvpn.com to learn more
i just went to my parents house for
thanksgiving
and happy to say my vpn worked there too
so i got to stream because i had frankly
really crappy wi-fi and i was a little
worried and it worked great this thing
works wherever it's easy to plug in
expressvpn.com yang visit expressvpn.com
yang and get three extra months of
expressvpn for free
so you were the president of basketball
operations at the pistons and that that
model has kind of fallen out of favor
uh where now people look at it and say i
don't know if one
human being can do these jobs because uh
they're very
disparate jobs um do you think that that
model is gone for good
where like no like it's just it's like
inadvisable
to task someone with both gmming and
monitoring all the talent transactions
and contracts on and all the rest of it
um and coaching or do you think that
could work if you know
like that if it was uh the right
situation an individual
yeah that that's a great question i i've
said this to people
every time i've i've talked about that i
said first of all
it's the only model that has always
worked
so teams become at some point you know
teams have become disenchanted with it
but if you look at what came before and
what came
after when that person had both jobs the
teams have always gotten better
and usually pretty significantly so
you know it's the only model it's a it's
a small sample size i understand
but it's the only model that has led to
improvement
every single time now i i think
and this is how it i sort of got into it
i think you're best
still with having two people
you know having somebody who's really
focused on
building the roster and taking a long
view because coaches take a short view
you know how we're going to win tonight
and the general manager's got to take
the long view so i think you're better
but you need alignment in your
organization you need everybody to be on
the same page and so
what happened in my situation andrew is
they had a headhunter
um calling and you know i remember i'm
sitting on my back porch
here in lake mary florida and i get a
call
and the guy says this is so and so and
you know
calling to see if you'd be interested in
coaching the detroit pistons and i said
absolutely not
and he said why not i said well that's
where coaches go to die
and they had had incredible turnover and
i said no i'm not interested
in that at all and then he called back a
day or two later
and said would you have interest in
doing both jobs
i had never thought about doing the
executive part of it
it wasn't really what necessarily
interested me but i knew if you had one
person doing both jobs the one thing you
would have
is great alignment you know i i didn't
participate yeah you have to talk to
yourself
that's exactly right and now there were
times i will admit
where our president me wanted to fire
our coach me
um but but at least the president never
followed through
on that so uh so we made it through
that would be funny be like hey got some
news
i mean for myself
[Laughter]
now so you had years of evaluating
various prospects making
very big investments where you know if
you decide to draft someone
or give someone a free agent deal uh you
know is a very big commitment
um was there do you have recollection
of someone who you just for whatever
reason
passed on or underestimated that wound
up being very successful in league and
you're like wow i didn't see that coming
like i didn't like i didn't think that
person actually had what it
had this or that um i'm just curious
because
it feels like that that evaluative
process is such like a
huge component of making a team
successful
yeah i think andrew you could maybe
get um 10 pistons fans on here
and they could definitely answer that
question for you on
people that i passed up on that became
very good and to be quite honest
um and and certainly nothing against any
of the guys that we did select but
the main reason i ended up losing my job
in detroit at least in my mind
is that we just didn't hit on the draft
i thought we did a pretty good job free
agents we did a really good job on
trades
i thought we coached the team well and
over our four years
um we won about nine to ten more games a
year than they had in the previous five
years so
we did improve it but the draft i mean
we missed
on we missed in consecutive years and
and there's probably more guys in this
but we moved
missed on devin booker who's become an
all-star
um out of kentucky and we missed on
karis levert who hasn't been an all-star
but
if if he can stay healthy and that's
actually the reason we passed on him
but if he can stay healthy is going to
be great and then we missed on
um donovan mitchell who has picked one
pick after us
and so you know you're not going to hit
them all in the draft
there's just no chance nobody does the
best personnel people in the league
don't
um but when you come into a tough
situation anyway and we came into a very
weak roster to begin with the draft
becomes even more important you can't
afford
to miss and and we bypass some uh
some really good players um and it's one
of the reasons
that i don't want to be in that role
again i mean if i ever get a chance in
the nba
i just want to coach that i'm very
confident i can do
that trying to project guys three and
four years out
is hard wow that's so interesting
um so to the extent that you've been
around people who
um and you're 100 right every team
in the league their fans can go over who
their
team drafted and who they quote unquote
should have drafted
and like there's no teams fans in the
league that are like oh
you know like our people are um
are perfect uh to the extent that there
are folks who have that projection
ability like what what do you think that
uh that gives someone the ability to
visualize what someone can do in the
league
um uh and as someone who is a
long-suffering knicks fan i mean
certainly
um whatever whatever whatever you know
you're about to describe
hopefully they could spread it around
the new york metro area
well you know i think it's this i think
that number one it's experience
um because one thing i noticed you know
with these scouts who have been at it a
long time
right so here's the one as a knicks fan
this probably made his sore point since
you
traded him but i remember being over in
spain
and we had gone over um to see kristops
porzingis
um it was porzingis's year and mario
hazonia
who the magic ended up drafting it was
their year and we went over there
to see them and there were a lot of
people
that you know were unsure
about porzingis who's obviously very
talented
but the veteran scouts and especially
the people who had
scouted in europe a lot they
were comparing kristaps porzingis
to paul gasol when pal gasol was 18.
and so i would hear people argue with
them because there were people who said
yeah i think he's going to be as good as
pal gasol
and you know people who didn't have that
length of experience were saying he's
got kind of
pau gasol pagasol was a great player
and in their mind they were comparing an
18 year old kristaps porzingis
with a 30 year old pal gasol well of
course pal gasol is a lot better but
those veteran scouts over in europe were
comparing
18 year old kristaps porzingis to 18
year old
pal gasol so i think experience is
number one
and i also just think
there's people who have a very clear
vision of what's going to work
what type of psychological attributes
and work ethic and body types
and skill sets and what can be developed
and what
can't be developed um the best i've ever
seen i've said it before
um there's a guy that nobody knows his
name in the nba
with the miami heat jet camera was the
director of player personnel for a long
time now he's more of a consultant
and you know he's hit on so many guys
udonis haslam
uh mike james and now you look at their
team
and you know duncan robinson maybe the
best three-point shooter in the league
kendrick nunn first team all rookie
those guys weren't even drafting
out of nowhere just freaking like like
picked them up
like uh not off the street because
obviously those guys are working very
hard but
but they're like there's no asset
involved they're like undrafted free
agents that you just developed
with a two-way contract uh or
um the g-league no but that's chet i
mean chet's been a guy
that throughout the entire time last 25
years of the heat
he's consistently found guys like that
and nobody knows his name he's never
been or even wanted to be a general
manager
what he doesn't want to do the contracts
and the negotiations
he wants to just evaluate players and
with like with duncan robinson i know he
told
eric spoelstra this is the best shooter
in the end
in the world this is the best shooter in
the world not playing in the nba right
now
so then they get him and then they
developing in the g
league and the whole thing so um
yeah i've always said if you can find
guys who get a lot more right than they
get wrong
the you want to pay them a lot of money
and hang on to them because it's a hard
thing
to do in a lot of cases it's hit and
miss but
they've been far above average san
antonio spurs
you know drafting ginobili in the second
round
drafting you know tony parker late in
the first round they've been able to do
it
um and when you can do that you know
your organization is going to have
sustained success
over time um but it's hard really hard
i i found myself rooting for this heat
team because they were comprised of
folks like duncan robinson who kind of
came out of nowhere
so i was running for president in new
hampshire which is where duncan is from
and i would run into
people who would tell me all about
duncan robinson when i was on the trail
he actually went to the same high school
i did too so it was like duncan robinson
i was like
wow i mean rightfully proud i mean
freaking guys in the nba but then he
became
uh you know cult hero and playoff hero
out of nowhere like like um you and jeff
started out in d3 he started out of
williams college and then he ended up
transferring uh
to a d1 school and then you know went
undrafted um
so that the organizations that perform
at a high level
in those roles like you at least i find
myself rooting for because
you kind of like people who do more with
less
and then there are the franchises who
seem to do less with more
that i think um andrew that people don't
pay enough attention to
as a reason for those team success is
we just mentioned miami and san antonio
they've had tremendous continuity and
stability
within their organization so eric
spoelstra's been with the heat
for 25 years pat riley's been with the
heat
for 25 years um all you know they're
assistant coaches they're
you know their vice president or they
might even be president now andy
ellisburg
26 years i mean everybody's been there
and they've been through
some tough times i mean i've heard i've
heard people say well yeah of course
they didn't fire anybody they always win
that's not true
going into this year that he did miss
the playoffs three out of the last five
years
but they weather the ups and downs and
what that continuity allows them to do
is they know the types of players
that they do well with and will win with
and
they just stick with it if they're doing
things right they realize there's a lot
of factors you can't control
injuries everything else and you're
gonna have to weather
nobody gets them all right you're gonna
have to weather some bad decisions
but we're gonna keep on going san
antonio has done it with more success
but they've had great consistency
because gregg popovich has been there
for 25 years uh and then the utah jazz
have had
three head coaches in my time in the
league jerry sloane ty corbin and now
quinn snyder
they've had great stability and again
there's an organization that after
malone and stockton
have had ups and downs but they stay the
course
and you know you'll hear it all the time
i don't care if it's
sports and business that you know you've
got to focus on process
over outcome and if your processes are
right eventually outcome will be good
if you take shortcuts to get an outcome
right away
you know it won't sustain and yet
in pro sports so few teams not just in
the nba
but elsewhere so few teams embrace
you know continuity and stability and
and i think that's one of the big
problems and i think it's one of the
reasons those teams
have done what they've done the
continuity and stability give rise to a
real culture
as well which is impossible if you just
keep swapping out
uh leaders and philosophies because then
you show up and be like i don't know
what this organization or this team
where this company stands for
whereas if there are some constant
principles
uh that you can keep sticking to
uh then it actually helps like you said
identify folks who belong in your
organization and don't um
just the fact that you can say like hey
this is a miami heat player
is an incredibly good sign for that
franchise you know
you know like you if you could say that
about uh someone then your
organization's probably gonna over
perform and that's true of business too
you've
really successful startups that invest
in
having a strong team culture and then
you can identify fit
more quickly and powerfully where if
you've got a really high functioning
organ someone doesn't fit
they tend to get rejected like a you
know a virus like that you
put the person there and then like
they'll be out of there in like a few
months uh
and and that's actually not a bad thing
necessarily that in some ways can be a
very good sign
well i agree with you and and um you
know first of all i think it's easier in
terms of your recruitment
if like if you're in the nba who are we
gonna you know
try to sign who are we gonna draft
because
you know the kind of people you're
looking for and that will eliminate
some people who might be really talented
but
they're not your kind of person right
and and like you say like if you go to
the miami heat
um i don't care if you're drafted traded
or go as a free agent
you know the reputation of the place you
know you're gonna be held to a high
standard in terms of conditioning
you know you're gonna work hard you know
you know all of these things
going in and so like if you're a free
agent if you're jimmy butler going to
the heat
you know exactly what you're going into
and so you've decided you
want to be part of that and so you're
full steam ahead
um i just don't know if if you can have
that like you say
if you don't build it over time and if
you're always changing nobody has any
idea
who you are and your own scouts don't
know like
what are we looking for tom izzo
at michigan state andrew he has a thing
on his recruiting board
and at the top it says okg and you ask
him what it stands for and it says our
kind of guys
that's who they're looking for like and
you'll hear him say it
and you'll hear the people with the
miami heat say it
we're not for everybody you know they
don't
hold an arrogance that they can just
take anybody and make them great no no
we need our kind of guys and that's what
they go looking for
yeah i think that's a a big competitive
edge
for those organizations because if you
don't know what you stand for then no
one else is going to know what you stand
for
it even i mean even if you're hammering
it it's like it's hard to actually
stand for the thing you say you're going
to stand for much less if you don't know
what it is
[Applause]
i recently just tweeted drink water
which is always a good idea
the more you're hydrated the better off
your body is going to be it's something
really easy
uh and healthy you can do for yourself
but a lot of us don't even do that
frankly i mean let's be honest so how
can you make it more
active and efficient take liquid iv
you put this stuff in water and then it
like supercharges water so you drink it
and it's like you're getting three times
the hydration
i know it's freaking magic of science so
that sounds like the kind of thing that
would actually
have you get the hydration you need
liquid
iv is for you it's one of those things i
wish we had on the campaign andrew
because what you're doing in the
campaign you're trying to stay sick
the whole time and you're just pounding
bottles of water and then frankly
you have to go to the bathroom the whole
time because you're just literally
pounding water all day long
in this case one of these is like three
plus bottles of water and it actually
tastes pretty good
i like the lemongrass ginger one that
i've done they've got one that literally
tastes like apple pie
it's kind of crazy watermelon's great
they got basic lemon lime too a ton of
different flavors and simple it's a
quick pouch
you can put it on the road throw it in
your suitcase throw in your backpack
it's great and it works you feel better
you feel like you don't need to drink so
much water because you literally
are hydrated you can get 25
off when you go to liquid iv.com and use
the code yang at checkout that's 25
percent off anything you order
when you use promo code yang at
liquidiv.com
get better hydration today liquidive.com
promo code yang
[Music]
[Applause]
you have been broadcasting out of the
bubble for the last number of months so
i congrats on making it out of the
bubble
um i got the sense that that for you the
bubble was a stone's throw away from
where you generally live right so at
least they had that going for it
like that there were some familiar
aspects yeah i was 40 minutes from home
it was yeah the the weather all that was
familiar in some ways it was harder
though you know because i knew i'm just
40 minutes away you know why
why am i not having dinner with my wife
and you know i'm down here for seven
weeks but
um you know some of the people i mean my
brother was there for
three months because i was out after the
second round of the playoffs he was
there from
start all the way through the finals i
think he got out
twice briefly they let him go home come
back and quarantine
and get in but for the most part maybe
for
other than about five days total he was
gone for
three months and he still has a daughter
in high school and
it was really really difficult um and
the players and coaches
were in an even more restrictive
environment and they were there for a
long time and you know a lot of those
guys have
young kids and everything else i mean it
was just
really hard and i think it was a mental
health
challenge for for a lot of people i mean
three months of being basically isolated
and it was tough and they were all smart
enough
right nobody was really complaining
about it because i think they all
they all know the reality you're making
millions of dollars nobody's gonna feel
sorry for you
and but the amount of money you're
making doesn't have anything to
do with the fact it's not gonna help you
get through
being separated from your family for a
long time
not having your friends around not
having the freedom
to move around i mean they were
literally in one compound
for three months now granted treated
very well and everything
it was a pleasant fishbowl but a
fishbowl nonetheless nonetheless
that's exactly right it would be like
being in um what people call
you know where a lot of white collar uh
you know
criminals go they call them uh club fed
yeah like country yes club fed country
club prisons and i always say yeah that
may be but you still
can't leave and that's what these
players were going through and these
guys
andrew as you know i mean you're young
you have a lot of money you have the
ultimate freedom i mean you can go
wherever you want you can get into any
event
you can hop on a private plane so they
go from having the
ultimate freedom to you literally stay
in in one small area for three months
uh i really uh admire the players
for what they were able to do and then
go out and perform at the level we all
watched in the bubble
for what it's worth i understood uh
probably better than uh
than most what the bubble meant um
because
i spent months on the road uh
campaigning
and like you said you're not allowed to
ever [ __ ] about it because
it's like you know like like in your
case it's like yeah you're a famous pro
athlete making millions of dollars like
crime your river
uh you know in my case it was like yeah
you know you're running for president
like you know
like crimea river um but i understood
what it meant to be away from your
family
uh for months continuously uh you know
if you have young kids and whatnot
i feel like the mental toll it would
take on people
is woefully underestimated where i feel
feel like it was such a huge part of the
bubble
and i saw a story where when they're
looking at
starting next season people are like no
way
bubble two or like you know like no way
we're going to do that again
to the same extent yeah i think it was
just really hard i mean
um the players did it and you know it's
one of those things i think
obviously they reached agreement the
players association with the league to
do it
and they did it i think for two reasons
one was obviously money probably the
biggest
um the players the owners everybody
stood to lose a lot of money
if they didn't come back and play and so
it was for that
but i think it was also to keep the nba
brand in front of people and to
entertain the fans and keep them engaged
so they did that and they knew what they
were getting into
but just as i'm sure you running for
president
like you willingly accept the challenges
you sort of
know you're going to be traveling a lot
or in their case staying in the bubble
but until you actually live it you don't
realize how hard
that's going to be so the nba is 81
black the nfl is 68 percent black
but the nba's return to play was in part
about
black lives matter uh social justice
messaging
and that became like a huge part of the
nba
really in a way i think was
unprecedented in american sports history
um was there a sense in returning to the
bubble that there was something
bigger at play than obviously the
money's a big deal
ensuring that there's a champion uh
entertaining people
but how much of the return to play was
motivated by a desire to try and do
something
positive at a time when a lot of the
country was struggling
yeah look i i think the pl you have to
give the players all the credit for that
and i'm a big adam silver fan
in the nba and adam's very progressive
guy
and certainly went along with things but
the players deserve the credit
because it was a condition of them
coming back you know the moment demanded
it
you know there's just moments in history
and so
while the pandemic locked down
united states amer you know united
states professional sports
um we had george floyd and brianna
taylor
and ahmad are barry uh
and others and so the players
took up that cause and a lot of them
were going to protests and rallies and
speaking and doing all those things
anyway
and then the nba comes along and wants
to restart and there was a lot of
discussion among the players of
should we be doing this should we be
playing basketball
at a time like this or should we all be
home in our communities
making an impact you know grassroots
level
and it took them discussions even among
themselves to decide
the platform that's provided to us when
we play
games the access we have to the media
when we're playing games
is more valuable and can reach a lot
more people than we can
just staying at home in our communities
i think it was a big part of their
decision number one
and then they said okay if we're gonna
play
let's negotiate with the league what can
we do you know and they got
as you said the messaging on the floor
the messaging on jerseys
and particularly in the early part of
the bubble
the players a lot of them would
start every press conference every media
availability they had
talking about some social justice racial
justice
cause i could get their first question
and say okay before i get into that
and they would talk about brianna taylor
or they would talk about george floyd or
they would talk more generally about
you know police violence which was
really their
issue at the beginning and then it was
great to watch them
sort of grow as the time went on all
andrew so
then they progressed as we got closer to
the election with voting
becoming their their major issue
and they were a little bit embarrassed
because the media
doing their research said these guys are
going to tell us to vote
20 of them are registered to vote
and chris paul as president of the
players association
took it upon himself and very quickly
like within days
90 of the players were registered to
vote
half of the teams had 100 percent
registration to vote
and then i think because of that they
just kept pushing forward with the
voting message so i
personally was really proud of them
for standing up and sort of forcing the
hand on messaging
but then also the growth i saw in the
players as time went on
yeah i feel like there must have been
some real growth
opportunities in the bubble like is it
terrible being separated from your
family for that long
yes but i i have a feeling that uh they
might have
ended up spending their time in ways
that they would not have spent it
otherwise
uh probably making some relationships
like in your case you're trapped with
jeff so
it was probably the longest time you've
been together as like adults and like uh
you know especially what with the nba
lifestyle um
did you see any of that did you see some
some people
uh i i suppose i mean the the fact that
they grew politically
is enormous uh were there positive
aspects of the bubble
oh there's no question you know i saw
people would
you know put on social media some of the
players like the books they
had brought into the bubble that
you know were regarding racial justice
social justice economic justice
um and then i know there were teams even
while they were in the bubble
uh doing zoom calls with
people to become educated or even to
advocate i know that
you know because steve clifford's a good
friend i know while orlando was in the
bubble
they did a zoom call with the sheriff of
orange county where all the games were
being played
there had been a police shooting of a
black man at a mall
in florida and it became controversial
because they wouldn't
immediately release the body cam
footage and so the magic had a call with
him and were able to ask him about that
and they were getting
guys involved in the process and other
teams
were doing that too and a lot of it was
they just had a lot of time all right
you go to practice
you're there for say three hours you
don't have a game that like what are you
doing
like you're not going home and going out
to a restaurant with your wife or
with your girlfriend or any so what are
you doing and i think
a lot of players really took advantage
of it
and one of the things i noticed watching
almost every game in the bubble and
listening to those press conferences is
how much more sophisticated the players
messages got
politically as time went on and so you
could tell
they were becoming more and more
informed throughout their time there
uh that's not surprising to me i was in
touch with a couple of uh
nba teams myself uh while you all were
in the bubble i did a zoom session
also just to rewind for a moment i was
an entrepreneurship
mentor to the nba players association
for the entrepreneurship boot camp that
they've had over the last number of
years
so you know i've been kind of an
extended
part of the nba orbit um and i got the
sense that teams were doing a lot to try
and
have their players have other ways to
uh spend their time really and to
develop
along some of these dimensions of
activism
um so that was to me i mean obviously
you never wish something like the bubble
on anyone but i thought to myself it's
like i think something positive is going
to come out of this
it has been tough to eat right to stay
healthy during this time i know we're
we're all there uh i don't know about
the rest of you just go into the kitchen
and just look for something to eat
well one of the things that's keeping us
healthy during this time
is athletic greens it contains 75
vitamins minerals and whole food sourced
ingredients
including a probiotic so you feel like
your gut is working better and it really
does feel like you're everything's
working
better if you ingest athletic greens
just mix it with water
down that thing and you feel like you
had a meals worth of nutrition and then
some
so one tasty scoop of athletic greens
contains 75 vitamins minerals
and whole food-sourced ingredients
including a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more
and they all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet
increase your energy and focus aid with
digestion and support a healthy immune
system
so i love this because it helps me with
my stomach just ever i can eat spicy
foods and i take athletic greens in the
beginning of the day
i have no problem digesting some of the
crazy things i normally eat
and i feel healthier when i do it and if
you decide to try athletic greens right
now you get a free one-year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs in case
you're doing some traveling
simply visit athletic greens.com yang
and join
experts athletes and health conscious
consumers around the world who make a
daily commitment to their health every
day that's
athleticgreens.comyang and get your free
year supply of vitamin d and five free
travel packs today
one question that i don't know how many
other people are fascinated by this but
i
am um so you are uh interviewing
with teams for an nba coaching job um
you know you're
again one of the most prized free agents
of nba coaches out there
what the heck does an nba coach job
interview even look like like i'm just
trying to imagine like if you brought
someone in
are you expected to have insight into
their current players is it more about
your philosophies
is about uh your chemistry with
management
uh like uh how how does that process
even unfold
yeah you know i've been through a few of
these um and
they're all different they're all really
really different um but it's it's always
sitting down with
uh you know general manager president um
whoever it is and a lot of it is
philosophically now i think it's
different
um probably for guys going in for their
first head coaching job
um i'm sure they get much more into the
x's and o's and uh and the strategy and
the details
but you know if i'm talking to a team
now
you have 11 years of watching my teams
play
like you have an idea if you like what
you see or not
so so i think it becomes more
um are we a fit are the way i do
business
and and operate as a coach am i going to
fit with what you want in the
organization and again
i think there's i say that coaches all
the time at every level
trying to get jobs the first thing you
have to realize is there's a lot more
good coaches
than there are jobs so there's going to
be a lot of good coaches
out of work at every level high school
college the nba and you have to
you have to realize that and then you
also have to realize and
this goes to that is you know it's not
who the best coach is because there's no
way to
to determine that you know i'm better
than
the next guy and then the next guy's
better than that you know
i mean it's all subjective i mean you
have some objective data but that goes
to the talent you have so
it's mainly subjective and i think what
the general managers and front office
guys are
looking for you alluded to it talking
about
a company you know developing a culture
and certain people fit into that better
than others fit into that and i think
that's the
once you have once you're interviewing
an experienced coach and you sort of
have an idea of the abilities that's
what you're trying to figure out
you know is he going to fit into this
culture is he what we want in that way
um at least that's been my experience
over the last
probably four times i've talked to
people
well for what it's worth i'm i'm rooting
for you to wind up the pelicans head
coach
uh we're friends of with jj redick over
here
he is actually a donor to universal
basic
income trial that we launched in upstate
new york
i have a lot of friends in new orleans
because i just spent a lot of time there
as well so for what it's worth just
throwing that out into the
the universe uh so you you've endorsed
joe biden
um you and i have connected on a number
of political topics
uh that we're both passionate about and
i remember you saw i saw a tweet from
you
championing local journalism which i
could not agree more with uh
universal healthcare and and universal
basic income you think should be on the
table now
given the nature of the crisis we're in
the midst of uh did you have like a an
arc
politically is it something that you and
your family were
interested in from a while ago or or did
you just uh
start paying more attention more
recently
uh i've always been engaged one of the
things i admire about the nba players is
they're a lot more active than i was at
that age i was pretty
self-centered at that point worried
about my own career
so i think i've been more active but i
was always engaged i grew up in a in a
you know my parents were conservative um
for me the ark was as i was i was always
socially pretty liberal you know i
just didn't understand why anybody cared
if you were
sleeping with somebody of the same sex
or what the
color of your skin was or any of those
things um
but i think i've certainly had an
arc in terms of economic issues
um you know i think at one point i was a
um you know balance the budget
guy um and still am to a degree
might the difference between me and and
conservatives would probably be i'd
i'd raise taxes and bring in more money
so we could help more people
um but recently right before
you started running for president so
these two things really
propelled me my wife and i had watched
it's probably a
three or four year old documentary that
robert reich did
um when he was teaching at cattle he
still is
and you know he was talking about
trickle down doesn't work yep you know
going up building the middle class so
people have more money to spend
that's what builds an economy and helps
everyone
and so we watched that made all kinds of
sense
trickle down has never made any sense to
me whatsoever
like this idea that they're gonna create
jobs up here like
i know i've never even run a business
but if i run a restaurant the only
reason
i'm gonna hire more waiters or
waitresses is i have more customers
like you can give me a tax break and put
another hundred thousand in my pocket
i'm not going out to hire anybody i'm
not gonna hire some more people unless
everybody's
gonna hire somebody if i have the need
to hire them so
robert reich made sense to me if now i
have more customers in my restaurant
i do better i hire more people they do
better
and so i watched that that made a lot of
sense i learned a lot from that
and then i mean within months
if if not even weeks after watching that
you're on stage talking about universal
basic income
which that idea goes exactly with that
putting more money in people's pockets
and
so i will say that's a more recent thing
to me
um within the last year of saying
wow this makes a lot of sense it's it's
not only
more humane fairer to people in our
society
but to me that helps everybody including
the people at the top
yep yeah if you're running a business
you know what you need you need
customers with money to show up
uh you know and if you're in an
environment right now where everyone is
being sent home
uh like it's like who are you gonna
profit from you know
you you look outside we can't all be
amazon you know i guess amazon's still
doing all right
uh so uh so this is the trickle up
economy and i i saw the same documentary
you saw by
um with robert reich and um he's been a
very powerful and consistent voice in
this direction
keeps on writing books keeps on pounding
the table making the case
and the economy's just gotten more and
more extreme over time
it was the most extreme winner take all
economy in the history of the world
pre-pandemic
and then the pandemic just turned
everything
up to 11 like it just sped everything up
well and here in central florida
we have felt it about as much as anybody
because
you know we don't have a lot of business
here i mean it's a tourism business and
we're in the service
you know it's a service economy so we
got a lot of people
working low-wage jobs here we have the
biggest affordable housing crisis
in the united states um because we're
playing we're paying people
10 12 15 an hour
and that's it and there's there's no
upward mobility
when you're running a ride at disney
world you know
and so we can make our unemployment
numbers look okay but those are not
high-paying jobs
and then when people quit traveling
and quit going to those things in a
pandemic
i mean it has really really been bad
i know the local the biggest local
food shelter uh in the area has
you know been doing about triple the
number of meals
that they normally do it's been really
really rough and it hasn't been
you know you would you would think i
mean for everybody this pandemic's been
rough
but you would think when you go through
a crisis that it should be
shared it should be a shared grief and a
shared
adversity and that's not the way it's
been you know
bernie sanders treats tweets out you
know one of your former opponents like
at least every other day tweets out how
much some of these billionaires have
made during the pandemic
and you know their net worth is going up
and we've got all these people who can't
eat
and that led to your tweet today which
is my favorite
and will probably be going up on a sign
in my room when i can get the
calligraphy done about
you know and i'm not reading the quote
right now but imagine
having the wherewithal to
you know solve people's problems
and then you don't do it i you know it's
i can't solve the problems that jeff
bezos can solve
but i've been lucky enough i can solve a
few people's problems
and you have to do it i i love that
tweet i've
sent it to i retweeted it but people not
on twitter i was sending out
to everybody today um and i think
that's where it should be we should
really be a community
a community of people who are helping
others um
but we can't help we can't count on
charity that's why to me
ubi and things like that like we can't
depend on
charity we need systems in place that
will help
people through this so well you know
one of the reasons why i think that
there's something universal about sports
and there's something universal about
coaching
where you form a community with your
team you know you're part of a group
you're on this together
and then you naturally want the same
kind of thing for our country when
you're going through a hard time it's
not like
the team's going through a hard time and
you just start ignoring people or
singling people out or just like pretend
some people don't exist it's like okay
who's
who's on the team like you know let's
come together
and here in america we have to all get
on the same team
really like that there's just too many
problems
that are facing folks for us to just
continue all of the this
strange uh uh
strange trend of just everyone blaming
the other side for everything uh for
turning on each other
and singing each other out it's it's
painful for me too
stan like it's painful for me to see our
country go through
this time and um have all these
self-inflicted wounds really
you know it's like like this would be a
very rough time even if we did
everything right
and i would say that for most of us
looking at it from the outside the nba
was an incredibly high functioning
organization
and did just about everything it could
do right right
at the bubble and then it's in the sharp
contrast to most of our other
institutions where everyone's looking
around being like who's supposed to be
running the show who's supposed to be
leading this uh the federal government
um like has not been leading
uh you know and and i think you're a
coach you're like a leader of man you're
a community builder
uh i think it's one of the reasons why
people love sports love the nba is that
there's something very human about that
uh and it feels like that's what the
country needs
right now yeah to me and i'm sure to you
too because i've heard you
speak a lot um the most frustrating
thing is
we have the wealth in this country we
have the resources
to do this and to take care of all of
our people now
there's countries in the world that are
very very poor
and don't have the wherewithal to take
care of
the problems in their country we have
the wealth to do that
and we just don't have the systems in
place
and we don't have the will or
to make the sacrifice to make this a
more
equal society where everybody can
share in this and that's what frustrates
me
if it was a shared experience and we
just don't have the money to help people
we do we have the money to do it
we everyone knows it now too stan when i
was running for president people would
be like oh
like how do we pay for that and then we
just watch uh
our congress write a 2.2 trillion dollar
check
mainly to the the biggest companies and
then you're just like oh
we could have done this the whole time
you know you can do it i mean you can do
universal basic income you can do
medicare for all
or some form of universal health care
you know whatever's best i'm not a i've
said to people like i
i'm not i'm not as smart as you or
bernie sanders or elizabeth warren and i
haven't gotten as deep into that
um but those possibilities are out there
and why we would choose as a wealthy
country
to have the levels of poverty we have to
have the number of people
without health care and without health
insurance that we have
is just mind-boggling to me and
it's a failure in our moral character
in our country and and there's no other
way to put that
i mean you just you can't sugarcoat that
you
have the resources to take care of these
problems you refuse to do it
your moral character is lacking i'm not
like that's not a partisan thing that's
that's just the truth yeah
and uh it should be apolitical to stan
it should just be human
uh and um unfortunately right now our
politics has become
uh inseparable from
uh from the media narratives uh from
frankly the corporate interests because
so many of our politicians
just have very very rich corporate
interests whispering in their ear all
the time
um i'd love to to change it i think we
have a chance to change it
uh in some measure after trump is out
and joe and kamala are
in i believe some very big things will
be on the table and really then the
challenge is going to be
can we get enough done in let's call it
four years
uh that people feel like we have
genuinely
started to come together and rebuild
that trust not
based upon statements but upon actually
improving people's day-to-day lives and
reality
like that that to me is going to be the
challenge over the next number of years
because if we fail in that
then people's mistrust and
that that disintegration of uh the sense
of community is just going to
accelerate as well i feel like we have a
window of opportunity here
that we have to take full advantage of i
may
play a role in that um but that's that's
where my head is going now
yeah and as you know i mean i
i think people are realistic we're not
going to
solve all the problems within a within a
four-year term but i think
we can start to solve them and i think
we can
show people in very concrete terms like
you say not in statements but in things
getting done
we can show people the possibilities of
what a better society
could look like for everybody in this
country
and we could set a direction of starting
to get there
that to me is what can happen and that
takes concrete things it's not just
statements but we start to turn around
and we get more money in people's pocket
heading toward hopefully at least some
form
of universal basic income and at least
we start working toward getting more
people
health insurance and you know all of
these problems
are we going to get it turned 180
degrees
in in four years no that's not realistic
but
can you turn it 60 degrees 70 degrees
and give people the feeling we're on the
right
track we can do these things we have the
resources
we have the leadership we can do these
things
that's what i'm hoping will happen over
the next four years i'm not
i'm not expecting joe biden kamala
harris people like you i hope in the
administration that's a great hope for
us i'm not
expecting like hey they took over
january of 21 and it's february now yep
we've got it all
i got my universal basic income check
and we're ready to go
yeah even if we do everything right
you're right that a lot of it's going to
be have we
made headway have we made progress and
it's a little bit like if you take over
a team you're not going to turn around
being like we're going to be champions
that's right like this year it's like
look give me a few years and hopefully
we'll have a direction we'll have a
culture we'll have a sense of trust
a sense of confidence um that that's
certainly
uh my vision for the next number of
years uh well stan
such a pleasure connecting with you and
a privilege i've been an admirer of uh
you and your work for a long time
you're a force for good the force for
community uh force for progress
in our country and i'm looking forward
to finding ways that we can work
together
one of my dreams is that uh that
universal basic income takes root in
communities around the country and i
think that people like you are going to
be a big part of it
i would love to help you in any way i
mean i i think that
you know my big biggest issue has just
been
justice and equality in every area
racial justice
you know um women's rights uh
you know lgbtq rights but economic
justice
is one that just cuts across all of
those
and for everybody and makes a true
difference
in people's lives and so if you ever
need my help even in a small way
i would be i would be happy to get on
board
because i think you've shown us a
blueprint now we just have to have the
uh
political will and courage to uh to give
it a shot
well thank you stan thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know every time we have a
new episode